ce soir on a annoncé expliqué le consul
on va revenir sur une partie de kolontar
et alors cyril avait fait un cadeau
énorme n'est fait une parodie de lara
fabian qui chantait la compagnie créole
là attention d'assez on a tendance nous
attend pas alors qu'une non on va perdre
le
[Musique]
cela fait plus de dix jours que l'
aventure a commencé sur l'île danas
et du côté de la tribune libre à cass
soc le moral est au plus bas avant nous
ennuie alors alors alors le temps chômé
pendant trois mois
papytel c'est une cata j'ai fait tous
les couacs ya pas une neuve pains qu on
est maire depuis une semaine
l'équipe n'a rien à manger et il va
falloir trouver une solution ces fonds
le canoë fin mais j'ai mon rêve en
couscous qui comme christophe dechavanne
parce que quand tu sais
[Applaudissements]
dans l'eau et les frênes j'aurais quand
même fini par bouffer
[Musique]
général fabian lucchi fait la compagnie
créole alors vous adorerez la compagnie
sa brillante avec leurs reprises
étonnantes de je t'aime décalé capable
d'égaler kamal je t'aime je t'aime comme
anna pour
[Musique]
mais aussi une formidable version 2 to
tout est fini
je la pense que ton
mais aussi la pétillante création de
gîtes seront encore pour les vivants
tant pour les photos j'y crois pas
encore
on est passé d'un blu ray face à jeter
alors retrouvé une heure une parodie
avec vous dans mes jeux merde am série
cultissime s'il en est c'est starsky et
hutch métier avec qui d'ailleurs dans
cet accord une scierie morose et moi
mais quand je dis si cyril g séries
qu'ils me répondent alors dont genève
merci beaucoup
oui donc avec thierry moreau jean luc
lemoine et camille combal et sertic qui
est ce qu on les reconnaissait jeu on se
parle alors du match et c'est l'heure
c'est daniel david soul et le blanc le
bleu
voici donc une parodie de ce car si
starsky et hutch et partie
[Musique]
rien
tu connais la dernière non madiba dans
ce jeu c'est pourquoi les martiens
l'ambiance je vais leur café donc
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont toujours des
secours il est pas trop en parler
on est à deux blocs on arrête tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] quand on voit chaque golez alors
pardon mais c'est quoi ces texans la
gêne pas je le sentais comme ça
hop
à
salut beauté mais si tu connais toi
ah bon vernal câblo californie je sais
que je regarde des 8
je l'ignoré totalement maggie un sorte
et maggie comment maggie les bons tuyaux
d'ailleurs propos de tuyaux journée 1
dans la culotte
ouais bah ça m'intéresse pas c'est un
bon sait-on en même temps tout couac
[Applaudissements]
la peinture est tout et merad cinéma ça
va vraiment bien du mal à bien bon et
pas toujours évident à des parodies on
faisait bon on en fait encore quelques
énarques à l'époque